[Music]
Micro has spent his life championing
ordinary people and yet not everyone is
appreciative Rose narrating a new season
of the Discovery Channel's how the
universe works
one viewer says he's not fit for the job
why well in facebook that if you argued
that row is quote anti education science
doubting ultra right-wing conservative
it ought to be replaced by either a
scientist or maybe better an actor
what's micros response to that will he
joins us in studio with that response a
mic the anti science huh
if only we could get an actor yeah just
someone kind of write down the into
someone's authority sure someone who
pretends for a living yeah so what was
this about who is this person by the way
I figured name was Rebecca and she was
one of the legions of Facebookers who
just kind of cruise around and had an
axe to grind and you know how it works
anybody can say anything to anybody
nowadays and I generally welcome
criticism in fact I kind of crave it
it's fun to mix up but but this woman
actually really got my attention because
she she copied everybody tagged
everybody including my bosses at the
production company my bosses at the
network and so she essentially said that
because she had an opinion of what my
opinions might be on certain things
those opinions of her opinion regarding
my opinion might not necessarily be
completely congruent with the opinions
of scientists that may or may not weigh
in on very specific topics learning the
workings of the universe so you know I'm
the narrator of this show I don't
improvise I walk in I sit down and I
talk in a crisp well-modulated baritone
and tell you about supernovas and
quasars and things like that I mind my
own business I sip my tea in a
climate-controlled booth I don't make
trouble with anybody any political
propaganda in between the scripts it's
the opposite of that
I take all opinion nuance and and
anything that could be remotely
concerned with the real attitude out of
my voice and just read somebody else's
what you always do that that's why this
story was so interesting and revealing
I thought I've watched you carefully for
I don't know more than 15 years probably
that's not weird at all well I've never
and I'm good at sniffing it out I've
never detected a political statement of
any kind from you at all you play it
straighter than anyone I've ever seen
Thanks that itself is now a political
statement it seems like that's what's
fascinating it's not what you say it's
what you don't and I'm not sure how we
measure or quantify it but we do and
there's a mysterious algorithm floating
around social media that that for a long
time if you said the wrong thing you
heard about it quickly now if you don't
say the right thing you hear about it
instantaneously and it makes the
conversation about the whole topic
nothing short of fascinating in fact I
thought of you when when I was
responding to her which I did in about
1,200 words I was on a plane trapped and
had some time on my hands and you know I
share your view about social media I
think there's a lot to be concerned
about yeah with regard to the way it's
used and I think I think one day I'll be
back here talking to you about the
parallels between the Second Amendment
and the First Amendment visa vie social
media and gun control I think what I
mean to say is it's a tool and and exact
how you use social media today is a
major conversation point and and and how
this woman used it and how I respond to
it and what I try to use it for with the
show I'm working on and how other people
choose to use it I think it's going to
be the issue of our times but you don't
care for whatever reason to share your
political views assuming you even have
any I don't even know if you happen I do
but you don't share them no you're
rigorous about not sharing them how long
can you keep that up well I mean I think
indefinitely but there's a difference
between hiding and not sharing all right
I've never dodged a direct question on
Facebook or or anywhere the difference
is if you're going to argue I run a
non-profit foundation right I mean Micro
Works is in its 10th year as you know we
raise money for work-ethic scholarships
and if you want to be taken even
modally seriously not just as a narrator
for show you didn't write but as the CEO
of a foundation with your name in it you
can have an opinion but if you're gonna
argue you argue from the middle right
you look at the facts as best you can
you ask for evidence which is the first
thing I did with with Rebecca her
accusations were very clear but for a
pro science person her case was
conspicuously void of what you might
call proof right so you can have a good
time and challenge people grown-up way
to at least at least create the illusion
of persuasiveness but if you can't do
that then you probably ought not own an
opinion and I'm never gonna ask you your
political opinions because I love the
fact that you stand as an island in a
world of people who can't wait to share
theirs and I lean in a storm island in a
storm you are harnessed wall mics right
great to see you as always thanks for
having thank you